like you're you know I know cuz working
with you I know for this for a fact that
Emily cap Nick are the the produce
executive producer of our show you're
her favorite how do you know I could
just tell the things she says she says
things to Oliver she says things other
people and Oliver says things to me I
know like oh my god that she that she
girls so amazing she's so funny I love
her and like she just talks about you a
lot yeah but not only do you have that
talent but you're a genetic mutation
what do you mean your face you out
you're like a porcelain yep just
perfection almost you know I want to
punch her face yeah just one cheekbone
I'll shatter the [ __ ] file alright
it'll just seep out of her ears and it
will be fine we'll be equals do you know
what first of all thank you that's very
nice because I know you're paying me a
compliment but I grew up sign a
compliment no my killer I grew up like
you know my mom's Korean my dad is white
guy yeah so I didn't really know what
people saw when they looked at me
however I was like in a business where
like I would always play like girl
number two or like the kid next door
like I knew I was an ethnic face but in
my school like I'd had a crush on the
football quarterback at school yeah and
at a party he was name his name's Joey
strike kula you know what I'm not even
sure if it was exactly him that said it
but the whole football team was in this
you know um I think we were watching a
movie oh no we're watching the Super
Bowl and Michael Jackson comes on I
don't know if it was an ad or he was
performing and he said oh my god Lindsey
looks exactly like Michael Jackson and
everyone started laughing and you know
what he's not wrong like I think that I
do look a bit a little after he did what
he did to his face that's what I'm
saying and so everyone thinks I've had
all this plastic surgery yeah yeah weird
and this is my face people like I'm
stupid
No mad like you know or Michael Jackson
now that I've told ya oh my god yeah
yeah yeah but now I have a thing
psychologically
where I can go is is she have a good
face no she looks like Michael Jackson
now I can just bring her down to my
level if I think about my well now I
won't hurt her I don't have to hurt her
I have to scratch your face or anything
like that
yeah cheeks can stay he's good staying
because even when you see that
commercial that Toys R Us commercial
you're just as soon as you see it you
number what it looks I kill oh there's
Lindsay right I'm picking my Colusa
Michael Jackson and then Merkel right
right a little white yeah they're white
yeah yeah he's a kid in it though super
so cute oh so cute
yeah you just want to take them home and
not know I'm the good uncle
yeah yeah Wow but like back to your
original question about like my kids
being in the business oh yeah like I was
able to I'm a super resilient person
just like you know some people are more
buoyant in the world so like when I get
a rejection I be like whatever no big
deal like I don't I didn't care about it
so much and even now like I love being
an actor but I'm not I don't know like I
just don't feel like it's everything and
I had that back then did you understand
rejection as a child big time and I
think it actually helped me because I'd
like really wanted to do something I
auditioned for Punky Brewster you know
Kathy Brewster yeah and I wanted it so
bad and I didn't get it and I remember
that was a heartbreak and also did you
ever see the neverending story and there
was the childlike Empress at the yeah
yeah yeah there's like a breath away
from being the choice so that one still
hurts but like since then I'm cool with
it
never next door yeah yeah let me ask you
this no but there's no rolls now that
you like didn't get that your boss a lot
of rolls there's I've just been able to
realize like not it's not my door to
walk there like why you couldn't you
realize this is that you know everyone
you know Tiger belly fans they've seen
my struggles they've heard you know my
my mishaps yeah and my little self
esteem and we're all broken children
everyone listening right now we're all
broken children what I've realized by
being on this show is it because it
happens so organically that it's like oh
I'm kind of meant to be on this thing I
don't know why
[Music]